there's a series of tracks here and this  is a Wolverine how can I tell size of  the tracks you know that's as a Big Damn  Wolverine kavik means Wolverine and  Eskimo the river was named because of  the amount of Wolverine on it only a  porkchop goes after Wolverine whether  twenty two so what I think I'm gonna do  is I'll get home one grab the 3030 and  do the rest of the perimeter with a  thirty thirty I don't want to go plan  for Armageddon but this is a little  thirty thirty a little bit more bam but  I did see really large Wolverine print  more than one set so I'm gonna feel more  comfortable having a larger caliber  rifle with going and finishing out more  of the perimeter no rest for the weary  but was that the wicked